and youth all of those who have
mobilized themselves to help us and the
global fund here today thank you thank
you from the bottom of my heart to Joe
Biden's President Biden's commitment
because with much professionalism also
we have been able to make some and thank
you to Bill Gates as well nevertheless
in these past few years and Peter
doesn't know this very well we have been
slowed down by the pandemic of covet 19.
now the global fund has bounced back by
mobilizing 4.4 billion additional
dollars
Health Services
a 20 drop to access to health services
and these are health systems that were
already significantly hampered
especially in the poorest countries in
the world especially on the African
continent and collectively now that we
are coming out very soon
much iniquity and inequality we have to
restructure our actions now we have
proven that an effective response that
ignores all Frontiers must bring
together everything vaccination of
course the development of new vaccines
and also access to the furthest line
regions and access to Innovation and
more Innovation and we have to work in a
system within a system with most
mdbs and public and private funds we
must together completely and utterly
consolidate what we have already
acquired the solution in this Health
crisis is that we cannot rely on a
two-pronged solution in the world and I
say this very frankly and very directly
however many billions we
investment level we must continue to
struggle because this will not be
possible without the very first Primary
Health Systems that have to be
structured that have to be built and
made more resilient because they are the
first Frontline
workers and of course we must read new
at the bilateral level in order for
there to be Access to Health Services in
the most vulnerable countries and for
the most vulnerable populations
and so in this replenishment
the global fund today France has decided
to commit fully once again within this
exercise hand in hand with you and I'm
pleased to announce
that we have decided to dedicate to the
global fund 300 million additional Euros
over the three-year period to come in
other words we will be investing 1.6
billion euros between 2023 and 2025.
[Applause]
you better
do much more than that with those three
diseases we will continue our fight in
order to have the price of medicine
this is the very role of the
international organization of purchasing
medication United and we will be
purchasing 250 million worth of
medication and products within the next
three years
is there anything and I'm saying this
here today because those two commitments
go hand in hand they are inseparable the
global fun teams know it very well this
United contribution will make it
possible to strengthen our contribution
and additionally to save six billion
dollars for the next three cycles and
refbellishments Cycles which is a very
crucial tool this has made it possible
for us to drop to heaven
because the medication against malaria
dropped by 70 and this is absolutely
considerable vis-a-vis beautiful in this
respect I should like to hope that in
2025 for the next replenishment cycle of
the global fund this takes place greatly
with United because we need to deal with
these tools simultaneously
thanks to this increase we desire to we
offer our confidence Visa in the global
fund and these are the main first I
would like to focus on first and
foremost we should insist on the
robustness of our health systems
everywhere in the world Health Systems
in the world that means we need to
master the invest quickly
holding on the 6 billion dollar Target
successively for the next three Cycles
consecutively it is crucial that we put
the country at the center the state at
the center and ultimately we should be
very pleased
there will be no longer any need for the
global fund to support because countries
themselves will be able to mobilize
their own resources so perhaps the
ultimate goal would be from the front to
disappear and ultimately each country
will be able to ensure its Health
sovereignty it's public health
sovereignty this is what each and every
country which is and the most vulnerable
countries hand-in-hand with the IMF the
World Bank
mdvs we will be able to do it and also
hang in hand with domestic resource
mobilization now I mustn't leave this
roster without insisting on Community
Health which are crucial for too long
and we've seen this during the cover
pandemic these have been left by the
wayside and I should like the fund to
launch launch in strategic Initiative
for training in Central and West Africa
and we will actively support such an
initiative
we must also fourthly support Global
Production local production rather
now a number of countries have been
begun to develop local production
capacity but we most also also shake
this and this must happen on the African
continent and in each country in order
to consolidate the medical sovereignty
and health sovereignty each country on
the African continent 20 percent of the
vaccination means are in Africa but they
only have two percent of the production
of vaccines we must Consolidated of
course procurement Diagnostic and
testing on the African continent on the
ground also supports United strategy and
also this replenishment process should
allow us to continue to fight against
gender inequality and gender inequity
especially for young girls and women
supporting them at a very Grassroots
level should be our utmost priority this
exercise
progress that we call new initiative
Itself by dedicating 20 percent of our
total contribution to that this
mechanism which is carried about our
French operator is dedicated to those
most vulnerable populations concretely
speaking in the 40 countries that they
have supported our mechanism makes it
possible
absorption and to ensure better
coordination amongst local actors and
also to provide technical expertise
expertise which is absolutely
indispensable we need to have these
additional resources but also for
training community health workers
services and of course hand-in-hand with
the university world and the private
sector because also with the local level
and the Grassroots level this is the
only way that it will be possible once
again
on behalf of the phone and for the fun
these Collective actions that we have
decided to take at the French government
level and what we do together and hand
in hand I want to end by saying this is
far from being over it is true that some
pandemics have dropped in some areas and
have reduced and been reduced but we
need to have better methods of
cooperation and alignment and in the
context that we are actually talking
about and in Conflict effective cases
and crisis affected countries thinking
of Ukraine right now we must support
them but we must also help them resist
and become resilient do absolutely
everything we can do and work instinctly
so that we succeed many young people who
are here today were nearly almost three
years ago there's one person who is not
amongst us to get with us today
who has HIV AIDS and suffers from HIV
AIDS she has a formula and something she
says which is
very strong and striking she just sent
three years ago and I will recall her
words don't forget don't forget that us
wait young Africans who have HIV AIDS
our lives have value
our lives have much more value than all
the commitments that we make and that
you make here today this is why it is
worthwhile to have this fight and to
succeed
Joe I think I am supposed to give you
the floor
yesterday
please welcome his Excellency Chancellor
Olaf Schultz of Germany
[Applause]
[Music]
President Biden Mr Sands excellencies
colleagues
I thank the United States for the
leadership on global health and for
hosting this important conference
as what was pointed out before the
global fund has made remarkable progress
against HIV tuberculosis and malaria
more than 44 Million Lives have been
saved however
the covid-19 pandemic has left this Mark
it has put many hard-fought gains in our
fight against these diseases at risk it
has exaggerated existing inequalities
especially in the care of affected
communities
we cannot allow the great achievements
of the global fund partnership to be
reversed
we the International Community must
intensify our efforts to support Global
fund Partners countries to respond to
the massive impact of the covid-19
pandemic
resilient and sustainable health systems
are the Cornerstone for fighting
infectious diseases such as AIDS
tuberculosis and malaria
but they are also a prerequisite for
Equitable Access to Health Services as
well as preventing and responding to any
other future pandemic
Germany therefore strongly welcomes the
global fund's goal to invest 6 billion
US Dollars specifically in Health
Systems including pandemic prevention
and preparedness
I'm pleased to announce the Germany will
contribute 1.3 billion Euro to the
global fund over the next three years
thank you
we are hopeful that this 30 increase
will contribute to reaching the
replenishment goal of 80 billion US
dollars
fight for what counts today tomorrow
until the job is done thank you
please welcome his Excellency Mr fumio
kishida Prime Minister of Japan
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it is a great pleasure for me to attend
the seventh replenishment Conference of
the global fund
I remember very well when I myself
hosted the Preparatory meeting of the
fifth replenishment in Tokyo as Minister
for foreign affairs
and I am happy to return today to the
global fund family as prime minister of
Japan
with the lessons learned from the
covid-19 pandemic Infectious Disease
Control and the strengthening of the
preparedness of future pandemics have
become more important than ever
I praise President Biden for hosting
today's conference
has been playing Amazing role in global
Health through its Investments it has
reached a remarkable achievement of
saving over 50 million lives from the
three major infectious diseases namely
HIV AIDS tuberculosis and malaria I
would like to upload the efforts and
contributions by all those who have made
this possible including executive
director and Mr sounds
those areas
our goal however is to end those
infectious diseases by 2013. and we
don't have much time left
to achieve this goal all all
stakeholders of the International
Community including donors implementing
countries the private sector and Civil
Society need to mobilize all efforts to
this end we need to further
domestic resource mobilization in
implementing countries and expand
Blended Finance projects with loans from
the World Bank we also hope to see
further contributions from new donors in
the private sector is thinking you know
a dear colleagues in the investment case
of the seventh replenishment of the
global fund strengthening of Health
Systems was explicitly set as a goal
adding to the traditional
countermeasures against the three major
infectious diseases strengthening Health
Systems will surely lead to better
preparedness for future pandemics and
will also contribute to achieving
universal health coverage
we need to unitedly work together to
accelerate this based on such
convictions I hereby we affirm Japan's
pledge
to contribute
up to um
zero eight billion dollars over the next
three years to the global fund which was
established after the ga crucial Okinawa
Summit
[Applause]
the Japanese government and related
organizations will take stronger
leadership in decision making
regarding the activities of the global
fund we will also make contributions
through Japan's Advanced Technologies
and Innovations
next year Japan will host the G7
Hiroshima Summit the Japan will continue
to take the lead in global health and
work together with stakeholders towards
strengthening Global Health architecture
which contributes to prevention
preparedness in response to Future
pandemics based on the global Health
strategy that Japan formulated last May
Japan Japan will also continue to lead
efforts towards achieving
UHC universal health coverage in the
post-coverage era in order to tackle a
wide range of global health issues that
has been disrupted by covet including
response to infectious diseases
that the global fund activities continue
to bring about tangible results
supported by the close Partnership of
all stakeholders
and now is the time to bring together
all the wisdom and determination of
everyone in the world and to take a
significant step towards building a
society where no one's help should be
left behind thank you
please welcome the right honorable
Justin Trudeau prime minister of Canada
who hosted the fifth replenishment in
2016.
foreign
[Music]
good afternoon my friends
the global fund was founded so that we
could tackle preventable and defeatable
diseases
through our regular replenishments we're
providing experts and communities with
the necessary resources to fight and
treat HIV AIDS tuberculosis and malaria
and keep people safe
with the repercussions of the covid-19
pandemic including the millions of lives
lost because of this illness it is more
important than ever to really attack
these and meet these challenges in
public health it's clear to us if our
populations are prosperous and healthy
our economies will also follow suit
Canada is proud to be a founding partner
of the global fund and we are proud to
have welcomed the fifth replenishment
conference in 2005. we are happy to see
today that the funds within the global
fund are used to advance sexual
reproductive health and related rights
and also to fight covet 19. interested
in Montreal in 2016. it was our fifth
replenishment this is our seventh
replenishment over the past 20 years
since this fund was launched we've seen
massive strides taken in fighting these
diseases saving an estimated 50 million
lives
we are living through a dark and stormy
time where things
can seem so somber
but when I look at what we've done
together in the face of diseases like
HIV AIDS which for decades ravaged
communities what I see is Hope
what I see is proof that our
institutions can work well and that as
leaders and as governments we have what
it takes to heal and help people
together through the global fund we have
forged a vast Global community of
scientists local experts and Civil
Society organizations
we are united in our work to strengthen
our health systems and prevent treat and
defeat these diseases
that's why Canada will be increasing by
30 percent over our last pledge and
commit
1.21 billion dollars to the global fund
and we will contribute a further 100
million dollars to the global fund's
ongoing covid-19 response in addition to
our previously pledged 125 million
and of course I know all of us here in
the front row encourage all other donors
to meet the 30 percent increase Target
so we can make sure we're maximizing our
efforts
[Applause]
to maintain the financial support that
they bring to other key Partners such as
unaids and the tuberculosis Alliance we
know and partnership we know that women
and girls are always less likely to have
access to vital treatments and I would
like to salute the fact that the global
fund
makes the most vulnerable people's
rights a priority including girls and
women now is the time to continue
fighting for those we have not reached
but I know together we can do it
thank you so much my friends
[Music]
please welcome Her Excellency Dr Ursula
Von delayan president of the European
Commission
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so dear friends excellencies ladies and
gentlemen
today's Gathering of leaders from across
the world is a powerful signal
because to most people no issue is more
important than health and well-being
and this is why I'm so grateful to you
Mr President Joe
for hosting this pledging event
we all know that Global cooperation and
solidarity are vital to end these
diseases
and the European Union has always been a
strong supporter of the global fund from
the very start
and how much have we achieved together
we heard it already
back in 2002 HIV diagnosis was in most
cases a death sentence
and millions died from tuberculosis and
malaria
if you think about
2002 it's not so long ago
but thanks to the initiatives Like This
Global fund it feels like a distant path
past
today millions of people are receiving
life-saving
anti-retroviral treatment
we can cure tuberculosis
we can prevent malaria
we can fight these terrible diseases
so we will end AIDS we will end
tuberculosis we will end malaria once
and for all this must be our pledge all
together
[Applause]
and yet the pandemic has shown
prevention is key
covid-19 not only caused millions of
deaths around the world
it had also a devastating impact on our
health systems
especially in low-income countries
and I therefore welcomed the prospect of
the global fund
to work even harder on the resilience of
Health Systems
the fund's commitment
to Foster local production of medicines
and Health Products is an important step
in this direction
this ties in with investment by the
European Union in support of local
production in Africa we spoke about it
and in Latin America
and we will complement these efforts
with our upcoming EU Global Health
strategy
now Justin you set the bar High
30 percent okay
I am proud to pledge another increase of
30 from the European Union
with
715 million euros
[Music]
and
and this will bring the overall pledge
of Team Europe team Europe is the
European Union the commission and the
member states
to over
4.3 billion euros
thanks to you
[Music]
this is money well invested in a
healthier safer more Equitable future
for all
and I'm sure Mr President dear Joe
that this pledging event today further
strengthens the global cooperation we
need in these days many things
now please turn your attention to the
screens for a final reminder of why we
are here today
of America
operations
A Million Lives children Brothers
communities but our fight is far from
finished and the world is in crisis once
again we must choose to fight for
workouts
tomorrow now until the job is finished
the fitting HIV TV and malaria by 2030.
Germans who lives
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
protecting Humanity from pandemics today
and tomorrow
[Music]
we can save 20 million more lives
[Applause]
[Music]
come out
[Music]
let's see what house
fries
please welcome to the stage Mr Bill
Gates co-chair of the Bill and Melinda
Gates Foundation
[Music]
well it's great to be here three years
later and thanks so much to President
Biden for hosting this replenishment
the gate Foundation uh houses one of its
proudest things being a founding member
of the global fund and gavi these two
funds have completely changed Global
Health uh and given people hope
for example
if you were a child who got malaria 20
years ago your chance of getting a drug
that worked was very small over a
million children died every year
we didn't even know about drug
resistance we weren't able to track the
disease we didn't have tests that were
working because this disease was only in
poor countries it was largely ignored
today that's very different we have
drugs that work in a pipeline to avoid
resistance we have better bed nets again
we're renewing those we're actually
tracking through genetics and Data
Systems exactly what's going on with
this disease and that is partly due to
the amazing work of the global fund
our foundation has is a top priority
putting billions a year into Innovative
new tools
and we can do that because we know the
global fund will be there to get those
out to the world
there's a lot of promising things coming
along better drugs better vaccines
better diagnostics for example we have
an attractive sugar bait that kills only
mosquitoes and can drop the disease
burden a lot we have a very cheap TB
diagnostic that will allow us to catch
the disease before you infect many other
people we have a TB vaccine that I will
be going into trials
so we're able to fund those new tools
because we know the global fund has
built the capability with Partnerships
and strengthening Health Systems to get
those Innovations delivered and save
millions of lives
and so the global fund itself you could
say is the most important innovation of
all
that's why our foundation is committing
an additional 152 million dollars for a
total of 912 million dollars over the
next three years
[Applause]
thank you it's a time of great need a
time of many challenges but it's
wonderful to see how we're all coming
here together to continue to help the
world's poor Us by solving these
diseases
it's now my great pleasure to Welcome to
the stage a great Champion against all
inequity and particularly the cause
we're meeting on today
uh the host of the global fund's seventh
replenishment conference President Joe
Biden
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
well friends fellow leaders Bill thank
you for the introduction
you know um
I want to thank you all for being here
not that uh you're here because we
invited you you'll be here no matter
what
and Bill thank you for your incredible
leadership and commitment to Global
health
and everyone participated in this
conference
and to all of you I want to thank you
thank you for fighting for what counts
this is all about saving lives there's
no ambiguity here working with Partners
to ensure that all communities are
healthy and strong at least have a shot
at being healthy and strong
but people everywhere can live in
dignity
it's hard to maintain your dignity when
you look at your child and see that they
are sick or ill with a disease that you
can't control
it's difficult it shocks you and it
deprives you of your dignity that's why
the United States is proud to be a
founding member of the global fund and
over the past 20 years through our work
together it's estimated the global fund
is saved as you heard before 50 million
lives
and dramatically dramatically reduce the
death rate of HIV tuberculosis and
malaria in the countries where it's
working
excuse me today
we've seen some historic pledges to keep
building on this incredible record
almost 1.6 billion I think I got it
right Euros from France 1.3 billion from
Germany one billion dollars from Japan
1.2 billion dollars from Canada
750 million euros from the European
commission and significant increases in
the private sector Qatar Republic of
Korea and from Nations that themselves
receive Global from Grants like Malawi
and Niger also contributed
and as I pledge to all of you the United
States will donate one billion dollars
for every 2 billion committed by the
rest of the world
so that means we're going to work
[Applause]
that means we're going to work with our
partners in Congress to contribute
another six billion dollars at a global
fund
I'll bring it
bringing the overall Global pledge as of
the day to 14 million dollars these
incredible contributions he succeeded
through our mutual and continuing
commitment to deliver one of the largest
fundraising and Global Health
fundraisers in global health history and
these billions are expected to deliver a
31 fold in return on investment 31-fold
return on investment
and in other words for every dollar to
fight these diseases we expect 31
dollars in health gains and economic
returns which also advances our progress
toward meeting the goal of sustainable
development agenda so let's challenge
ourselves to keep going
do even more it's an investment that
will save another 20 million lives
reduce mortality
from these diseases another 64 percent
in the next four years
it will support Frontline health workers
prove and by the way they deserve
special special special thanks for what
they've done especially when it was much
more dangerous than it is today
it will improve
surveillance capabilities build stronger
more resilient Health Supply chains and
increase Innovations to reach those most
in need and it's going to help prevent
and respond to gender-based violence and
Advance sexual and Reproductive Rights
and health outcomes for people around
the world
you know as we as we work together the
United States will also continue to
advance our leadership through our own
health investments in pepfar the
president's malaria initiative and
efforts to fight TV TB these Investments
working in Tandem and further amplifying
the work of global fund have helped turn
the HIV aids around and develop the
world's first vaccine for malaria here
in the United States we're almost 1.2
million people are living with HIV we're
implementing our new National HIV AIDS
strategy to accelerate and strengthen
our national response to the HIV
epidemic we're putting Equity at the
core of our efforts we have to ensure
that everyone no matter who they are who
they love where they come from can
access care and treatment they need
period
folks
and that they're treated with the
dignity they deserve everyone should be
able to lead a healthy productive and
fulfilling life that's our goal so thank
you all for stepping up especially in a
challenging global economic environment
and I ask you to keep it going let's
finish this fight together now is the
moment to accelerate our efforts to
reduce Health inequities and to address
barriers to access including gender and
human rights barriers to build a more
inclusive Health Care Systems to leave
no one behind to end AIDS tuberculosis
of malaria for good let's demonstrate
our Collective power to take on
challenges matter most in people's lives
and deliver progress we have so much so
much to do so let's get to work and
thank you all for all you're doing God
bless you all
[Music]
uh Mr President thank you
at the end of such a momentous event
the word thank you seems kind of
inadequate but for all the Millions
whose lives will be saved
for the communities where life will be
transformed thank you so thank you
President Biden for your outstanding
leadership what's happened today is
actually an unparalleled unparalleled
mobilization of resources for Global
health
we're talking
14.25 billion US Dollars without two of
the global funds largest donors who we
fully expect to pledge in due course
thank you also to the presidents of the
DRC Kenya Rwanda Senegal and South
Africa for co-hosting the launch of this
campaign in February thank you to
everyone in this room and for all those
supporting us from far away heads of
state ministers Partners advocates
to our donors I say thank you we know
these are challenging times competing
demands fiscal pressures we know you
have gone the extra mile thank you to
all of you from civil society and
communities your passion your
determination is an inspiration to us
all together we can end htb in malaria
and make a better world free of the fear
and pain of infectious disease a world
where no one is Left Behind and today
with your help we have taken a giant
step towards making this happen and I
would like to invite joining me and the
president on stage for a photo miss
Connie mudenda
foreign
Minister Justin Trudeau
and Mr Bill Gates
do you know how to do that brilliant
the man who knows the technology
[Applause]
[Music]